[Aplausos]
las cosas
andamos derecho
y yo
[Música]
también
y ya está
entonces de ellos que siendo seres
humanos
y también actualmente soy
y bueno
[Música]
i
necesito
voy a hacer
bueno
[Música]
y
aquí
[Música]
ah
bueno
y ese momento queda toda la fecha no
logró vencer
[Música]
y esa persona siente de implicación
mis papás
[Música]
un fútbol más tiempo lo conocemos
natación todos los momentos
en este momento
[Música]
y
pero
pero bueno y ahora se llega a mí
[Música]
no puede ser
interesante
y
todos
[Música]
y
no
clava
para todos
y
mejor reporte
[Música]
por qué
no pues
[Música]
y aquí
el ads esto es escolar
[Música]
por qué
este chico
quería
y las cosas
y es importante saber si estamos que
dibujar correcto
y si a los demás
hay que regresar nuestras cosas
interactuar por esto
yo sabía que en el ámbito de la máquina
y
[Música]
y no hay tiempo y seguro para elaborar
las cosas
pero encuentro
tiene aspiraciones
entonces vamos a aprovechar
[Música]
entonces voy a comentar
destaca
nosotros
realmente así
ahora
amén
y tenemos que pensar eso
porque si empezamos pero si empieza a
caminar
[Música]
pero más personas algo que me encanta
que lo encontrarás en los años
hoy vamos a ver
el termo baliza que me encontré hace
unos años
y esta vida tiene cosas tienen unos
objetivos
[Música]
para muchas cosas y este
dice que vamos a tener gris
y
ganar
[Música]
llega poca presión
entonces
[Música]
porque es importante ser una entidad de
esto
porque me encanta esta promoción
y no puedo creer
ya no lo tengo
como el estrés se inicia en carrera
por tanto a vosotros con las manos
lo que hacemos
así
[Música]
estado
en nuestros días vamos a comentar
y entonces estaríamos
ah
[Música]
y qué
no tengo
espero que no
lo que te
a mí me dice usted
a ganas de arroz ahora
[Música]
internacional
aprendizaje
a los pinceles
y
deja problema
i
el día
[Música]
como empresa
siempre se apostaron diferente tu mamá
entonces
[Música]
te digo
dice
[Música]
cómo
de día
[Música]
y
por ciento
y así fue cómo hacer cada uno de estos
tres niveles
así es como a mí cada talento
a los que no tenían como
y esos sueños
y todos los costos
[Música]
y hoy en parís
ah
pero adicional que es pero sí
hoy ha venido un poco más
porque no es fácil
[Música]
y la verdad
muchas veces tenemos más american esas
cosas
le damos una oportunidad
[Música]
mismo
igual entonces nuestra mente
entonces esperen las dos semanas que
esos candados se van a nosotros
[Música]
y puedo trabajar
algunos tratados
en la escuela
pero
son estos
y no vamos a llegar
[Música]
esto fue en 2010
mis libros
es un evento de todos modos
familias de nuestra vida y por qué
aquí
[Música]
tuvimos el séptimo lugar
qué
y fue también
termino siguiendo de tus claves ya
habréis rato
[Música]
ah
juegos
es algo gracioso responde la persona en
la relación
a saber
[Aplausos]
[Música]